Nik Craig is deputy prime minister and
leader of the Liberal Democrats and says
his is the party of in Nigel Farage is
the leader of the UK Independence Party
and is equally unequivocal he wants out
ladies and gentlemen please welcome Nick
Clegg and Nigel Faraj this debate is
about you
and it's really simple because it's
about your job but if not your job the
job of someone else that you know and
it's about making sure that the
sacrifices that you have made to fix our
economy aren't wasted because make no
mistake if we cut ourselves off from
Europe from the countries that we trade
with more than anyone else
then our hard-won economic recovery will
simply be thrown away it's also about
who we are a Britain that leads in the
world by standing tall in our own
European backyard of Britain prepared to
work with other countries on the things
we can't possibly sort out on our own
so don't let you kit or anyone else put
all of that at risk we're better off in
Europe richer stronger safer and that's
why I will fight to keep us in for the
sake of jobs for the sake of our clout
in the world for the sake of Britain
we're having this debate at last is
taken a very long time just imagine
though we weren't debating whether we
should stay or leave just imagine we
were debating whether we should join the
European Union and I put it to you then
what we ought to do is vote yes in a
referendum to join a club that will cost
us 55 million pounds a day as a
membership fee that will give us
thousands of new laws over which our own
Parliament and new the electorate can
make no difference
it'll mean an open border
unconditionally to 485 million people
from across the whole of Europe many of
them from very poor countries and they
can come here and work and live and
settle and bring their families and do
as they wish and it would also mean that
we would have to cut our links with
other parts of the world the
Commonwealth the Anglosphere
and many other parts of the world
because we'd lose the ability to make
our own trade deals I know the result of
that referendum you wouldn't join it the
debate here today
is between a tired status quo defending
a crumbling European Union that frankly
isn't working anymore and a fresh
approach which says let's be friendly
with Europe let's trade with Europe but
not be governed by their institution I
wonder if I can read you the words from
a very prominent politician back in 2008
it's time to give the British people a
real referendum on Britain's membership
of the European Union and there we are
there's a very fresh-faced carefree
politician there in that poster why are
we still waiting well if everyone can
read the small print I suspect you can't
what it's said no no I don't mean a
small print I mean in the leaflet what
it said was at the time you were
debating a new change in the rules which
is exactly what I was just referring to
a debit at the time in 2008 there was a
new treaty the Lisbon Treaty this is the
treaty whereas Nigel for ours rightly
points out the conservative party
changed radically their attitude towards
it I was exactly had exactly the same
view in 2008 2009 2010 namely when the
rules change when new things are asked
of you powers which rightly belong to
you then it is your decision in a
referendum the trauma is your defining
transfer of powers in terms of treaties
there is a possibility that actually
there won't be any treaty change because
in fact what's happened since the since
your beloved euro has gone into a
tailspin is without using treaties
they've managed with the eurozone
countries to acquire yet more power a
censor and surely you know there is a
very urgent need to have this this isn't
flipper and I accept and everybody in
this room over the age of 55 live but
there are many in this room who voted as
my parents did yes
but they voted yes to a common market so
I got here in leaflets chronological
probably can I can I just can I just
finish the point this is a leaflet that
the other Nigel courageous party
distributed in the recent East Lee
by-election you may remember it it says
here that 29 million remains and
bulgarian x' may come to this country
there aren't even twenty nine million
Romanians of Bulgaria Bulgarian living
in Romania and Bulgaria
it is simply not
so you know let's let's have this debate
John but let's have it based on fact let
me give you one more fact one out of
seven of every company new company
created in this country are created by
people who come here pay their taxes
play by the rules I didn't answer the
question you try to do trickery with the
29million saying the round twenty ler
you know why cuz two million have left
already and they've gone and they've
gone to Italy and the Spain Nick you can
answer the basic question I'm not
claiming twenty nine million people have
the right to come to Britain I'm
claiming 485 million people have the
total unconditional right to come to
this country if they want to and I think
you're less right quite right your point
the fact is let me know if we're members
of the European Union we have the
complete free flow of people are you
denying that yes it is not unqualified
denied it is not the case that anyone
can move to this country and simply
claim benefits simply delivering better
week let me keep doing benefits like
we're talking about the free movement of
people I don't understand in pursuing
legal withdrawal during the European
Union we would make our country poor if
we did what you kids said the jobs would
go Nigel foreign direct investment is an
important point it is a key point and I
so well remember Nick you and all your
gang all the big corporates all telling
us 12 years ago that if we didn't join
the euro remember that if we didn't join
the euro all investment into Britain
would cease the City of London would
disappear and all I can say is thank God
we didn't listen to you otherwise we'd
have been in one hell of a mess my view
is we shouldn't be sacrificing a single
job a single job just to fulfill this
dogmatic view that we should turn our
backs on the rest of the world and on on
Europe it three million jobs is 3
million pay packets is millions of
families in this country being able to
pay their bills which they otherwise
wouldn't really that's why this is at
the end of the day about jobs
Joe Joe I say there is no
once again Nick you just show you know
you don't really stand the worlds of
commerce and trade do you know what the
World Trade Organization meets to
discuss global trade the British
representative to shown the door and
asked to leave the world's sixth largest
trading nation the world's eighth
largest manufacturing nation is not
allowed to be present in the rooms not
true because we're members of a European
Union so we have to be represented by a
Dutch bureaucrat his name no one knows
and who nobody can vote for a quite
extraordinary state of affairs we are
banned forbidden from making our own
trade deals you know with countries like
India or Canada or Australia or New
Zealand people who would have a drop of
a hat sign trade deals with us we are
prevented from doing so and you know the
reason is people like Nick don't think
Britain's good enough we're just not
good enough
we unlike Nigel for us I actually before
I went into politics was involved in
these trade negotiations it is simply
not true what you've just heard how on
earth is it possible for YouTube to
claim it is somehow patriotic to make
our streets less safe is it possible
that you can claim that somehow you're
standing up for prefer if you would not
actually be tried extradite and bring
back right hundreds of people just face
British justice business of the heart
this really gets to the heart doesn't it
of the differences between us and by the
way I don't agree with Nick we signed we
signed our first extradition treaty in
this country 1174 850 years ago we
currently have extradition treaties with
92 different countries all over the
world yes we have to cooperate on
cross-border crime we do it through
extradition treaties and we do it
through organizations like Interpol
which we've been working in since 1923
all right I of course want us to have
sensible extradition laws not just with
the EU but all over the world you can
arrest it in Spain because I think you
haven't done you may be left up to 18
months in prison without even facing a
charge we have a system of common law in
this country we've had it for 800 years
why did you think is based why these
variance measures to disgrace tourists
it is based on the presumption of
innocence before guilt it is based on
habeas corpus and Khai or why don't we
why don't you think that against we must
defend the principles of liberty freedom
and justice in addition you should
defend we suppose mr. right the motive
citizens why did you no I have not
noticed equate
I'm moderating this debate thank you I
have not you might respond to a question
that was put twice I've made of the
European Parliament now 15 years they're
getting a bit cheesed off of me over
there I got to tell you and I have not I
have not voted in 15 years for one
single piece of legislation that has
added to the power base of the European
Commission in Brussels even when it
meant British tourists you might mean a
British tourist who get caught up when
on holiday for the translation they need
help they need lawyers they need I
believe why is it that you keep dogma is
so strong now you won't even help
British our risk when they're on the
wrong side of the law actually the House
of Commons has shown that roughly 7
percent 7 percent of all new laws are
related to the European Union but they
do need to be there that's 7 percent in
order to make sure that you or need
anybody else who's exporting into the
rest of the European Union can do so
without fear that the rules are somehow
going to work against you thank you mr.
quick Nigel Faraj give you some seconds
up I see and what are you on about
we had one of your friends from Brussels
Commissioner Viviane Reding in London
the other week say we must all sign up
to United States of Europe and we must
recognized the importance of Brussels
because after all it makes 70% of our
laws even Gordon Brown said over half
our laws are made in Brussels so if you
believe as I do even if you haven't
voted for the Liberal Democrats before
but if you believe that we're better off
in there not least on this occasion on
May the 22nd in the European elections I
hope you will give us your support
thanks to Blake thank you
a minute for you
trade with Europe cooperation with
Europe friendship with Europe but I'm
British I believe the best people to
govern Britain are the British people
themselves and I believe that by
divorcing ourselves from this failed
project not only will be free Britain
will provide a good example for much of
the rest of Europe we're going to fight
damn hard in the next few weeks and put
that choice on the ballot paper for you
on May the 22nd Nigel Faraj thank you
for that
[Applause]